hello everyone and welcome to the second
the day of the air things masters so
we're starting off with a game between
alexandra costanuca and magnus carlson
it's quite a wild one and you guys will
enjoy it so uh without further ado let's
dive straight into it alexandra with the
white pieces opens with e4 and she is
yes the only woman in the tournament and
she is uh
well much lower rated than the than the
rest of the field but uh she is playing
some very very interesting games and
we'll see uh how much um well damage you
will be able to do uh first they did not
go well to her uh for her she lost all
four games but she had an incredibly
strong opponent she played guillermo i
think uh
let me just check i don't want to trick
you guys
uh who are the opponents exactly uh so
first round she played against duda
second game arunyan uh third game majira
for the game manish uh and she lost all
four of them and magnus well he also did
not have a great first today but he did
not lose four games so that's a very
important game to start off day two so
uh like i said alexandra opens with e4
and magnus replies with c5 as he usually
does against the e4 opening uh knight to
f3 with e6 and now not going for the
standard uh d4 or bishop to b5 but
rather c3 going for the alapin variation
uh and the magnus replies in a very uh
principled manner and that is of course
pawn to d5 the pawn is on c3 uh so we're
not worried about uh captures and even
capturing with the queen since you
cannot place a knight on c3 again free
tempo on the queen
uh so here e captures on d5
but now not queen captures magnus
instead goes for e captures on d5 we
have d4 and now knight to c6 so this is
all very standard stuff uh bishop to b5
we have bishop to d6 by magnus and the
castles by alexander we have knight to
f6
and now while you could deliver a check
here it's not really all that impressive
black can just block with bishop to e6
so instead
d captures on c5 forcing magnus to waste
the tempo bishop captures in c5 and now
knight to d4
improving the position of the knight but
also putting some pressure on the c6
square as it's now attacked twice but
magnus uh doesn't really uh i find it
this interesting he just castles
interestingly uh this position is a
known one bishop to d7 and also bishop
captures sunday for our known moves here
but magnus just castles and he offers up
the pawn on
on b7 basically but you can't capture
this move and of course it is as of move
9 that we have a completely new game uh
if alexander goes after the pawn then
it's uh well bad news for example
captures capture cs the rook is hanging
but there's knight g4 and uh well how
are you how are you defending against
this uh if you capture the rook then
comes queen to h4 with the threat of
checkmate but also the f2 pawn is
attacked three times and once you defend
this let's say h3
uh knight captures an f2 let's say
bishop captures queen captures or even
better uh you could play rook captures
and after bishop captures now king to h1
there's bishop characters on h3 maybe
even a better defense for white but it
is not enough so here everything just
loses uh if bishop f4 trying to hide
like this then bishop g4 opens up a
discovery uh wins the wins the white
queen so it would be hopeless so
whatever you do it's just a bad idea so
of course not grabbing the pawn bishop
to e3 as she continues development and
now you could again go for knight to g4
it's a very nice move the queen can
maybe come to h4 the bishop on e3 is the
target
but magnus decides to
just keep it very solid we have queen to
d6 and now h3 alexander realizes that
there could be something happening so
the g4 square should be covered and the
should be back to b6 now a very
important move uh as you do not want to
trade this bishop however you do want to
place it on c7 and as the white knight
is not on f3 guarding the h2 square
bishop c7 queen d6 battery will uh will
probably be able to do a lot of damage
so knight d2 and here knight captures on
d4 c captures on d4 and the bishop to f5
a very nice developing square for the
light square bishop uh we have knight
back to f3 and now rook a to c8
occupying the open c file
and the while uh alexander could place
maybe the rook on c1 uh it is uh more
important to play something like bishop
to d3 and eliminate uh one of one of the
bishops so here knight to e4 magnus
decides that he is going to keep
material on the board he doesn't want to
trade and now queen to b3 alexander
develops the queen connects the rooks uh
and well i just asks magnus what is your
plan here and you might uh think magnus
will play something like rook f the e8
you might i think he's going to play
rook to c7 maybe double up
rooks on the c file those are all very
good moves maybe play rook c7 and then
double up on the e file this way but no
he plays a rook c to e8 and it's a
really weird move to see since you're
locking
in your own rook on a f8 but i think
magnus was really just anticipating
alexandra's next move because the pieces
are placed as they are so the next move
from white does seem to be logical now
now you should continue with something
like rook the c1 rook c2 double up rooks
on the c file or maybe a4 a5 uh
completely ignoring what uh black is
doing as it's really weird
but she played knight to e5 and she sort
of plays right into carlson's hands as
she runs into f6 and now
okay it's a weakening of magnus's
position but also it um gives him
additional support for executing g5 and
h5 and that's what he's going for so a
knight back to f3
and now you wouldn't be able to play g5
here because it's covered by the bishop
and the knight but the existence of the
pawn on f6 makes it possible so here
magnus goes g5
and okay rook after c1 she's now ready
to double up rooks on the c file but now
uh we have h5 preparing to bust open the
position with the g4 so knight to d2 and
now king to g7 if the position opens up
magnus wants to be able to bring his
rooks into the attack so bishop captures
an e4 with bishop captures and the
knight captures uh she eliminates two of
the attackers but now rook captures on
e4 uh and and now comes a4
so not not a lot to do with white but
wait and see what those pawns will do
rook to f7 a very interesting move by
magnus magnus doesn't even play bishop
to c7 which is kind of the move you want
to play you don't really care about the
g3 or something like that you can just
easily open up the position point is uh
alexander would very happily give up the
rook for uh for the bishop here so
magnus doesn't even allow this he plays
rook to f7 first and he says i'm gonna
play bishop the c7 but then if you trade
i wanna play rook captures on c7 and
have my own rook on the open c file so
rook the c8 and now she's bringing the
other rook to c1 and only now bishop to
c7 so now this doesn't really
do all that much because we're just
going to capture on c7 and control the
c1 square so she brings the other rook
into the action with rook uh the c1 and
now magnus just goes for queen to h2
with check king to f1 and now bishop to
f4 uh very very nicely done saying that
okay if you capture the bishop then
queen h1 is checkmate the rook now
controls the e file so you have to try
something else queen captures on d5 was
played attacking the rook but now queen
h1 check king e2 queen captures on g2
guarding the rook and after king to d1
queen to f3 with check we have king to
c2 and now of course the position is
completely winning for magnus but we
always have to play that absolute uh
best move otherwise we
allow our opponent an opportunity to get
back into the game so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the
absolute
best move for for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting
anything either bishop captures an e3 or
rook captures an e3 or even queen
captures an h3 is fine but rook captures
an e3 is the absolute best so
congratulations to everyone who decided
for this move as he was in this position
on move 30 that alexandra costano
resigned the game uh as there is nothing
more uh to be done here now you just
capture the piece and you are
threatening to pick up the queen and
there really isn't anything better uh
you
you have to trade here after queen
captures we're gonna play rook captures
here uh and now we're just up a full
bishop and well there's just no counter
play here for white so whatever you do
after this rook captures on e3 is simply
insufficient uh and of course uh she
knows this and that's why the game was
resigned in this position
uh so
really a nice start and you can see how
she play she played a
well a brilliant game up until the point
where she allowed magnus this tricky
idea of course the game is not lost
after knight to e5 but it just gives
black this very very annoying uh counter
play uh with just allowing the the spawn
push g5 h5 g4 and it's not like i said
it's not of course lost but it's so easy
to play this uh with black uh the the
moves just you know
appear in front of you and with white
you have to play play brilliantly to
just stay alive and of course you know
that bishop to c7 is coming i mean how
do you how do you even
start defending this especially in a
rapid time format uh so yeah uh that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank lucifer 45
non-commercial ep uh they'll cook onward
the 95 american flag numa david kimura
and the dog reynolds for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the air
things masters until it finishes uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day